What's up guys?
Paddling season continues out wise
crack.
So last month we piled it a show called
the film tourist.
It was on the wolf of Wall Street.
If you haven't seen that one yet,
be sure to check it out.
This is the second episode in that
series.
This one is on the shining.
Before we get to it,
this video is sponsored by movie,
a curated online cinema streaming
exceptional films from around the globe
so you can get your 30 day free trial at
movie.com/wise
crack and along with the show Stanley
Kubrick's,
the shining or the world's most
persuasive argument for taking the
stairs.
This movie scares the shit out of
everyone,
but why all this for you there
it's hard to say.
What exactly is wrong with this place is
haunted.
Is it all in their heads?
Is it possessed by the Devil Tony?
Something about an Indian burial ground.
They located on an Indian burial ground.
Where else?
A lot of traditional horror gives us an
easy to understand reason to shirt dark
pants.
The shining deliberately avoids an
easily describable premise and this is
part of what makes it so damn
horrifying.
It deprives us of logical explanation.
Koop rick accomplishes this in a variety
of ways,
but I'm here at the overlook hotel to
talk about one of the most surprisingly
simple perspective.
One of the most effective ways to create
a stronger sense of perspective is
through the way it's shot is framed and
sequenced.
See,
a shot can be objective,
subjective,
or fall somewhere in between.
Purely objective shots.
Show us a scene as it is a God's eye
point of view as a poor eavesdropping or
watching a play.
Subjective ankles directly insert us
into the action showing the view from
just beside or behind a character.
Purely subjective shots take us directly
into the eyes of a character.
Usually by showing their face first
followed by their visual perspective or
emotional experience can also invite us
to question what we're seeing like an
unreliable narrator in literature.
In this scene we see a shot up Danny's
face that a cut to the girls.
Then Danny's face again with this simple
sequence of shots were being shown.
The events through Danny's mind.
Let's see how cooper it takes this basic
principle perspective to create an
indescribable supernatural feeling.
Consider the famous scene of Danny
riding his tricycle through the hotel's
winding corridors and you give me some
skin.
All right.
Using a state of the art piece of
equipment for the time who brick is able
to achieve supernaturally smooth
movements.
To follow Danny showing us the hotel
from a child's point of view.
We followed danny any traditional
subjective shot that emphasizes his
experience navigating a large maze like
hotel,
but we don't follow him perfectly.
Watch how the camera lingers after he's
left frame and then hurries to catch up
with him.
One film scholar calls this the
wandering camera because the camera
ambles along like it's own sentient
being or here and imagined monster
stocking danny through the halls.
This grates the sense the hotel is alive
and watching Danny through his vacation.
When the twins show up,
we move more intimately into a
subjective sequence of Danny's pov
flashing between his bloody visions.
Danny covers his eyes,
looks again,
and now they're gone.
So perhaps the girls are just in his
head by starting with Danny's point of
view as we follow him,
but then shifting to a possible camera
monsters point of view and then back to
Danny's may be unreliable own vision.
The film undermines our ability to
interpret the events in front of us
whose point of view is this,
Dan?
He's the hotel,
some demon that,
let's consider Jack is all this creepy
stuff in his head too.
Did someone just spike the water with
Lsd in this otherwise normal hotel?
Take this scene in the apparently empty
gold ballroom.
In this scene,
we go from a closeup of Jack as a
seemingly addresses an invisible being,
the reveal shot of Lloyd.
This subjective sequencing of shots
could suggest that Jack is hallucinating
and just when we're sure that this is
all a subjective delusion,
kubrick moves the camera backward over
his shoulder,
taking the shot from his direct point of
view to a more objective one.
From there,
Kubrick gives the scene and objective
reality by showing both characters in a
shot together,
Lloyd's the real deal.
We think until Wendy shows up and the
ballrooms suddenly empty and we're left
totally confused and creeped hours,
so what's going on?
We don't know.
And the camera work makes sure we'll
never find out.
Now at times Jack's point of view even
seems to merge with that of the imagine
Predator that was following Danny in
this shot.
Jack's view looking down on the model
hedge maze,
Glen's into an aerial view of his family
wandering through the actual hedges.
This effect happens again as he chases
Danny in the final scene.
See how the same kind of shot that used
to be stuffing Danny through the halls
has now mingled with Jack's point of
view.
Further confounding the various
supernatural elements of the film.
We're not using point of view to screw
with reality.
Kubrick also uses our perception of
physical space to creep us out.
How do you make a huge otherwise normal
hotel and presented as a claustrophobic
nightmare?
Kubrick is famous for what is called one
point perspective,
which adds to the cramped field with one
point perspective.
Near perfect symmetry draws the
audience's eye to the one vanishing
point at the center of the frame,
giving this sensation that we're being
drawn into the shot,
which is further enhanced by the
tracking shot inward.
It feels uneasy like the walls are
collapsing inwards.
That's why even though the overlook
hotel seems like a spacious setting,
we feel increasingly cramped as the
movie goes on,
almost like claustrophobic rear,
which can occur when people are shunning
together over long periods of time by
juxtaposing large spaces with much
smaller ones,
Kubrick is able to get the viewer to
feel really claustrophobic.
This starts with the opening shot of the
mountain,
which cuts to the shot of the family
clown car style.
Then we moved from the large sweeping
hotel lobby to the Torrance is small
hotel corridors.
While the hotel may be large,
the torrance is are trapped and
increasingly smaller spaces within it.
Eventually Jack ends up locked in a
fridge.
Danny escapes through a tiny window and
nobody has any elbow room.
Through these tricks and perspective.
Stanley Kubrick is able to add a layer
of creepiness that if aid simple
description,
and that's why the shining is so great
and why film nerds will continue to talk
about it for years to come.
There's so much more to talk about in
the shining.
So if you liked this video,
let us know if you want us to do
another.
And as always,
thanks for watching peace.
All right guys,
hope you enjoy that.
We've got a couple more coming out
before the end of the year.
So this episode is brought to you by
movie.
Those of you who listened to our movie
podcasts,
you know that movie has been gracious
enough to support us there as well.
And because of them we're able to
continue making episodes of the film
tourists.
So movie is a curated online cinema that
focuses on procedures,
films,
festival hits and beloved classics.
There are always 30 perfectly curated
movies on the site.
Every day they present a new film and
every day they take one away.
Movies are really great way to discover
international directors you might not be
exposed to otherwise.
Recently movie has been featuring the
works of Hong Kong filmmaker Johnny Tow,
who was famous for making really awesome
gangster films.
I watched the film triad election in
college and it catapulted my love for
Hong Kong cinema.
That movie is playing now on movie along
with other johnny tow films like mad
detective and vengeance.
So if you like gangster movies,
you're going to love Johnny Toe.
And if you like discovering new cinema,
you're going to love movie.
So try a movie free for 30 days at
[inaudible] dot com slash wise crack.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash wise
crack for your extended free trial.
Thanks to movie for supporting us and as
always,
please.